hello and welcome to the special episode
of women techmakers my name is alex
meyer and i'm the community manager at
Google cloud platform today with me are
Karen Sandler the executive director of
the genome foundation hello Karen hi axe
how's it going pretty good and just to
be here and I'm so excited to talk about
the outreach program for women thank you
absolutely happy to have you on the show
my second guest today is marina rocky
neskaya who is the community lead at Red
Hat how are you doing marina yes hi I'm
Jen Whelan very excited to be on the
program as well wonderful so as he
mentioned earlier we are here to talk
about the women outreach program at
kinome marina can you tell us a little
bit about it right so the very first
kind of precursory program was the
women's summer outreach program that was
done by the known foundation in 2006 and
the reason we did said was that we
participated in google summer of code as
a great opportunities that Google has
for students to have paid remote
internships working with a mentor on an
open source project and we participate
in that program since 2005 when it
started and in 2006 we had 180
applicants and none of them appeared to
be women so that was the first times
that when Hannah walk and Chris bowl put
together at two months program very
similar to google Summer of Code and
when they put this call out they in fact
had a hundred applicants for the program
and over the next few years we noticed
that that did not actually leave a
lasting impact on our community so in
2009 when I was one of the eight women
at the conference and one of the four
women who were software developers with
the project from among about a thousand
contributors and we still had maybe one
or no women in google summer of code is
here we decided to kind of reinvent
gurman and start offering the
internships how long is the program have
been in existence since 2010 and we had
had a hundred thirty participants would
do two rounds a year because we have to
catch up so much and we are noticing
that their advantages to both doing kind
of may through august round and at
december to march around and in
particular december to march around
appeals to student in this students in
the southern hemisphere but two main
differences from google summer of code
is that we are actually open to non
students as well and that is a big part
of our participants are not students and
also we have non-coding tasks in
addition to coding tasks oh that's great
so Karen what is known foundations role
in all of this also the chrome
foundation organized the program we
originally founded the program it was
for the genome project and we found that
the program had such a big impact on our
project it was bringing so many
extraordinary women we went from having
as marina said four percent women at our
annual conference which is called Gua
tech to having this year we recently had
eighteen percent which is often a
statistic given as the number of women
in proprietary software and the the gap
between free software and proprietary
software was very wide in terms of how
many women that were participating which
was really surprising so so we've had
this this major change in a gnome and
because it was so good for no we decided
we couldn't keep it to ourselves so what
we did was we opened it up to other free
software projects who also were
interested in trying to help solve this
problem so we now have over 20 projects
participating in the outreach program
for women including the Linux kernel and
Mozilla at Wikimedia a lot of great
organizations we have both debian and
fedora it's it's it's pretty fun and
different projects participate during
different rounds and the gnome
foundation serves as the as the overall
organizer for the project as as Googlers
know the summer summer of code is a is a
massive and inspirational program it's
amazing but it's it's I honestly have no
idea how Google handles it it's such a
big and amazing project
but but for us having this smaller
program where we now have in this
particular round we have you know around
30 participants you know it's it's a lot
for a small nonprofit organization to
handle but we do so for for all of the
free software projects participating and
I think it works out well this is great
so um have you experienced any gross in
the past manito since 2010 in the number
of participants or trying to keep it
steady oh absolutely and we started with
about 10 participants around with a
genome project but and then karen was
the one who when she stepped in as the
executive director she suggested that we
expand the program and first we did a
pilot round expanding the program to
just one project which was the twisted
project was the software freedom
Conservancy and as any programmer knows
expanding 122 is almost as hard as
expanding as two too many so that was
like the first step and then after that
when we expanded to heaven about 10
participating organizations in this
round we have had about 30 participants
denisha round for the last three rounds
this is great so what kind of tasks can
women expect when they participate in
your program what can they choose from
so there's really a wide variety of
tasks that or projects that that women
can work on when they join the outreach
program for women as marina was saying
one of the the key differences between
outreach program for women and google
summer of code is that our program
welcomes women in to do other things
that are non-coding tasks which is
really valuable for attracting women to
free software so for example we have
marketing internships and design
internships and things like that and you
know I think it's it's it's several
things one is that it's an
acknowledgement that free software and
software in general need so much more
than just coding and having you know
valuing contributions in those fields is
really important another thing is that
sometimes women who are interested in
coding find it a little more accessible
to come in and some of those other
projects so I for example had an intern
who I was the mentor for who who did
marketing
she had such a good experience with her
outreach program for women that she took
coding classes and she participated in
summer of code so we have some of that
happening as well so I think it's it's
it's twofold it's valuing the non-coding
side of free software and also
recognizing that that you know helping
women build communities with you know
build relationships within our community
is also really valuable so how would a
woman who wanted to participate in this
program are be able to join what does
she need to do and what can she expect
when she first establishes contact so
what we require of all the participating
organizations is to have a list of
mentors who are available anytime
throughout the year for the prospective
participants to approach and to work
with informally on contributing to the
project and a very strong and
requirement that we have visit program
for the applicants is that they need to
make irrelevant contribution during
their application process and we offer
the informal mentorship and help during
that time so just going over the
available organizations and available
projects and conducting a mentor and
just following the guidelines from the
organization about how to get started
and actually getting started diving in
is the best recipe for planning to apply
I love this part of the program because
it basically assists applicants and
getting involved in free software
projects so even we have to be very
selective we don't have funding for a
lot of spots and so it's very hard to
always choose the women that we wind up
selecting but all of the women who apply
have the opportunity to work with a
mentor and have the opportunity to
become a contributor to a free and open
source software project so just the
application process alone is really
valuable to go through and we do find
that women who go through the process
sometimes even if they didn't get the
internship during the time that they
applied if they stuck around and
continued continue to contribute they
become a much stronger candidate for the
next round and so even though you know
we get many more applicants than we can
except every woman who completes an
application has become a contributor to
a free and open source software project
and I think that's pretty cool yeah and
I've seen a lot of our participants
describes this first contribution as
something that got them hooked that
showed them how addictive contributing
to free software is because it's a
thrill to be able to see your changes go
out and be publicly available and be
making a difference in a project that's
available to anybody and can help
somebody and a lot of people are using
around the world so a lot of people have
described it as addictive and I'd also
like to mention that another requirement
that we have for our interns is to blog
every two weeks and their blogs have
been aggregated on the women in free
software planet and that's an amazing
boost to to read that planet and to see
what they are doing during their
internships that says and also gives
invisibility so is there a website of
that women who are interested in your
program can visit and learn more and
maybe participate absolutely you should
go to a gorg slashed opw and you'll find
information about our program how to
apply what participating organizations
there are and who is participating now
and when is the next round opening it is
a the application deadline is very
similar in a time to google summer of
code for utter referral for women it's
March 19 for google Summer of Code it's
March 21st so what would do for our maze
for all this round is that we parallels
the days for google summer of code
because part of what would like to do is
kind of going back to the original
motivation for the program we want to
encourage more women who are students
who are coders to apply for google
Summer of Code and that's part of what
we do with the program and so for
example last summer there were ten
percent of the participants of google
Summer of Code where women and the
organizations that also participated in
outer screw for women had fourteen
percent women among the participants in
google Summer of Code yeah one example
of that
that is Wikimedia for example in all of
the years are participating in Summer of
Code they had only ever had one
applicant and after participating in one
round of summer of code they had seven
female participants in summer of code so
the program has been really working it's
amazing this is great and I mean the
numbers the percentages that you're
naming are absolutely not typical in you
know in the industry and particularly in
the open source project so great kudos
for you for running this google has been
a really strong sponsor since the
beginning of the program aside from just
providing the model of summer of code
and the fact that the two programs
really work together Google sponsorship
has been really important thank you
absolutely well thank you very much for
coming on the program Karen and marina
i'm looking forward to welcome you back
on the show again sometime thank you
very much for watching my name is alex
meyer and this says women techmakers